jan sagen dieses jahres hatten wir schon
darüber berichtet ihnen macht weltraum
firma spacex mit der falcon 9 rakete
habe das erste mal einen satelliten mit
einer wieder verwendbaren antriebs
rakete ins weltall geschickt jetzt will
europa nachziehen
die europäische weltraumorganisation esa
entwickelt derzeit ein mehrfach
verwendbarer raum fahrzeug der
unbemannte space reiter soll schon im
jahr 2021 in die erdumlaufbahn fliegen
und dann später wieder auf die erde
zurückkehren können was der space 3 da
alles kann und ob europa damit
tatsächlich seine eigenständigkeit in
der raumfahrt zurückerobern kann jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen am 30 november war es soweit
die europäische weltraumagentur esa hat
einen vertrag zum space rider
unterschrieben der plan wird also
konkret erst einmal geht es noch um die
knapp 37 millionen euro schwere
planungsphase doch danach soll es direkt
an die umsetzung gehen der erste
testflug vom space rider ist schon für
2021 eingesetzt der konkrete plan space
raider wird vom europäischen
weltraumbahnhof in kourou zu seiner
reise ins all aufbrechen
das soll mit hilfe einer wg rakete
passieren vega ist italienisch und steht
für vito europäer die generationen avant
sata also übersetzt so etwas wie
fortgeschrittenen generation einer
europäischen trägerrakete es handelt
sich dabei um eine vierstufige
trägerrakete für satelliten die im
auftrag der esa entwickelt worden ist
nach zwei monaten im niedrigen erdorbit
also einer höhe von etwa 400 kilometern
soll ein modul des raumfahrzeuges wieder
in die atmosphäre eintreten und dann
möglichst sanft und unbeschädigt auf der
erde landen space weiter soll als labor
fungieren mit dem experimente in der
schwerelosigkeit getestet werden zudem
sollen neue technologien aus formiert
werden technisch gesehen basiert das
projekt space rider auf dem
experimentellen raumfahrzeug die xv das
steht für intermediate experimente wege
seien testflug fand im jahr 2015 statt
danach landete es im pazifik und genau
das ist der entscheidende punkt bisher
hat europa mit der esa zwar das
potenzial satelliten und so weiter ins
all zu schicken
der knackpunkt dabei ist aber sie wieder
heil
erde zu bringen damit hinkt europa
tatsächlich weit hinterher
mit dem space reiter will die esa also
jetzt seine stellung in sachen weltraum
know-how raumfahrt ausbauen denn wir
haben darüber berichtet die usa sind da
unter anderem mit neuen akteuren auf dem
markt ganz ganz vorne mit dabei unter
anderem eben auch ihren mast weltraum
firma spacex vor allem im bereich der
trägerraketen ist der kostendruck und
auch der wettbewerb auf diesem markt
enorm gestiegen schon im märz 2017 hat
das basics wiederverwendbare weltraum
flieger ins all gebracht und zwar
erfolgreich die falcon 9 rakete war
tatsächlich sicher auf einer
schwimmenden plattform im atlantik
gelandet nach maß hat die die
entwicklung solcher wiederverwendbaren
antriebsraketen allerdings 15 jahre
gedauert
höchste zeit also für die esa
nachzuziehen auch deswegen gab es wohl
eine weitere vertragsunterschrift von
seiten der esa zusammen mit lv will die
europäische weltraumagentur sich um die
optimierung der europäischen vega rakete
kümmern und die pläne auf dem papier
bezüglich des pays reiter sind
wahrhaftig optimistisch jedes
raumfahrzeug soll 800 kilogramm
transportieren können also fast eine
tonne
jedes von ihnen soll sechsmal in den
weltraum geschickt werden können
pro flug werden dafür 40 millionen euro
kalkuliert nach angaben der esa gibt es
auch schon konkretes interesse an dem
projekt beispielsweise von seiten der
pharmaindustrie wenn er kein video zur
weiteren entwicklung verpassen wollte
das wird mir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue
videos informiert hier geht es weiter
mit und dafür draufklicken neues
zeitalter der raumfahrt eingeleitet neue
space extraction ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran